up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to a video talking about just
how oh we're so oppressed as women and
like oh you know big feminism video uh
pull up the video king what have you
personally experienced discrimination
when it could pay because of your gender
there's highly opinionated male energy
women have way more opportunities than
men
and Below them can't do the job women
are portrayed as weaker um
we have a woman president yet so today
I'm out here and the question I'll be
asking dear God please don't give us a
woman president oh I'm gonna just say a
prayer now
father son Holy Spirit dear God I could
accept a woman vice president maybe if
it was Candice Owens that's it if it was
Candace Owens but dear God please do not
give us a woman president hell will
freeze over please please is the gender
pay Gap real yes it is men get paid more
for whatever they do and women get less
for doing the same amount totally agree
with that one thing that people forget
about the pay Gap there are certain jobs
that men do that women do not do
honestly I think it depends on the
industry I'm a physical therapist the
ratio between male and female is about
equal so and I don't really see a
difference in terms of pain majority of
time in a lot of corporate roles yes
when there's higher roles it typically
is given to men men are more why why are
they given to men is it possible is it
possible and maybe women don't want to
do those jobs call me crazy I don't I
don't know don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
Bell the way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos like the video on
your way anise that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams even things women
are more interested in people but also
if you're a girl who happens to be
interested in things then you're
probably gonna make the same amount of
money what in the gender pay Gap in your
instance be explained based on an
individual choice and the industries
that they choose it's individual choice
that is building a system around us men
and women are different it is based a
lot on the choices and how would you
spend your time if you work hard you can
do whatever you want
um we have a woman
no but what do you think that dear God
no I said again God please no you would
like the pig out there's highly
opinionated male energy we
we have been deprived of
to express World Peace what are some
rights that men have that like women
don't then
men's District
more than women even in the same
position of power do you work like a job
at the moment uh no I know
oh the audacity oh my God I work I don't
see it but in general looking at other
friends in other Industries and then
knowing what they're making in
comparison to what their peers are
making it's real
so it's become an accepted reality
amongst most that women make around 82
cents to a dollar compared to men women
were paid 82 cents to every dollar paid
to men let's make sure women earn pay
that's equal to their efforts and
despite potential flaws in the stuff
there is no way
you know what's crazy the older I get
when you're young
I mean like you think some of this stuff
is true
but their Obama was what 35
37 he was like in his late mid to late
30s when he became president there is no
way he didn't know the pay Gap isn't
real that it's based on like the
industries women pick and the hours it's
like why is this guy pandering pandering
undeniable progress made by women as 40
of women now make more than the medium
male compared to just 13 40 years ago
but with incidents like the US Women's
soccer team's lawsuit for equal pay
attention surrounding gender and
inequality oh my gosh I am so tired of
hearing these women soccer players and
all these female athletes whining
whining whining about pay I am so tired
of hearing these women whining about
equal pay just whining whining whining
whining whining oh boo hoo poor me I'm
not paid enough it's just like I am a
semi-pro athlete okay so one I play for
free I play for for free and I have
offered Pro contract so I could have
went pro in the fall and this is what
you don't realize the reason that we
don't get paid is because we have empty
seats like I'm sorry guys if we're not
entertaining enough that men want to
watch then quit whining about it and be
more entertaining it's like I mean let's
just call Spade to Spade if we wanted to
make money we would just start taking
our clothes off let's just now I'm not
gonna do that but you guys you guys get
the idea it's like we can't be mad about
outcomes when there's a reason we're
paid less stop whining or higher than
ever
stadiums we've
we've recorded and yet despite all of
this we're still paid less than our male
counterparts considering because they
make more money and I know they
manipulated some stat to make it seem
like the women make more money but they
don't we all know they don't I don't
give a how you're going to
manipulate the statistics to make it
seem like you make more money you do not
make more money than the men very no way
I think studies on both sides it's
important we explore the Nuance not only
individually but on a societal and
Global level but in today's lack of
nuances it considered sexist to even
question commonly held truths and more
importantly is equality even achievable
of something we even want I guess we
gonna see so let's say that if the pay
Gap does exist right and the employers
can get away with paying women less
wouldn't more jobs want to hire more
women than men especially men in power
think that women below them can't do the
job as well so that's one of the reasons
they do get paid less they want men to
fill those roles because they want the
men to go up in power it's again
trusting word over women's as a woman
you have to do more to prove that you
deserve it more have you personally
experienced discrimination when it comes
to pay because of your gender yeah
definitely me asking for a raise would
definitely impact me staying there
compared to other people there oh my
gosh oh my gosh so you got rejected for
a raise maybe you're just not good at
your job that's exactly what I was gonna
say you had nothing to do I'm sure it
had to do with having a woman maybe she
just wasn't good enough to earn the race
you know from hiring women and men
women always
I'll say women are much more likely to
ask for crazy things than men I'm just
gonna say that women are way more likely
than men to ask for crazy things they
don't deserve
you know men are just
some I don't know guys and this is the
thing now it's a sex thing when maybe
it's just how you do your job thing
possible you know it should be
predicated on skill I'm a woman you're a
man and we go for the same job we should
both get the same opportunity because
I'm starting to see now people are not
getting jobs because companies they have
to fill those jobs so that it looks good
on their ends quota yet a quota Case by
case it all depends the more complex the
issue the more important it becomes to
explore the Nuance but when we look
closely at the individual are there
consistent patterns that lead to success
if so does a person's gender really
matter in general do you think there are
differences though when it comes to
competitiveness risk taking and ambition
between men and women in general that
contributes to different pays I don't
think personality and characteristics
have anything to do with how successful
you can be in corporate role wait really
you don't think any effect at all I
think no there is gonna be some effects
it depends on what exactly you're doing
in the company as well women are more
agreeable and sometimes they can just
say you know okay to things when it's
actually not okay and they probably
should you know push forward a little
bit more like for me I actually was
thinking about this I think women would
get paid equally if their husbands
interviewed and negotiated for them
you know what I mean like I was like men
are just this is why I have my dad yeah
I I have my dad do a lot of things for
me when it comes to like budgeting and
all that stuff because as a woman we
just like say yes to things for some of
my girlfriends we had to personally push
for like a promotion whereas we have a
co-worker oh no I had to push for a
promotion
you offered this promotion to me so
that's just one example from like myself
maybe they did better work
I don't know and so even in the absence
of blatant discrimination hidden
barriers often exist that only some
group's face so I wanted to hear it
personally what do you think some
barriers are that like women face in the
workplace I have the funny thing is is
actually counter-intuitive why would a
successful company hire and in copy an
incompetent meal just because it's male
they wouldn't the more successful a
company is the more important it is that
the people that they promote are
competent and they get rewarded for
hiring women so it's like is there a no
barriers I don't care what anyone says
scared to take like maternity leave
because what if they come back and
they're behind sexuality I just thought
of something in fact I think the more
quotas a company has the more they have
to ensure that the people that are
actually doing the work are like the
best of the best because then they have
to carry the weight of I'll tell you it
was I'll tell you what else too it's
like what women do is we'll start we'll
we'll sue too you know honestly for the
amount of women that are suing for
sexism and the amount of women that are
are suing first
if I was a man like if I was a man and I
had a company I would stop hiring women
because we want to be in a man's world
we want to be in the workforce but then
we don't like the way that men are and
it's not to say that you should be hurt
at work but women call husband
everything and the other thing is women
will flirt with the men and when the men
flirt back then we start whining about
yet we don't talk about how we flirted
too
or if a woman
this is her boss she doesn't get in
trouble but if a man flirts with the
intern now it's crazy it's just like you
know people used to meet their husbands
at work so what's acceptable what's not
acceptable now you know I understand
like you know you you gotta keep things
PG like whatever you can't have people
breaking up and whatever at work I get
that but it's like you guys are gonna
sue for her husband when it's like a lot
of y'all were flirting back whatever are
we getting promoted based on our level
of intelligence or are we only given an
opportunity of how much we can give or
those favors so it's clear that women
face a unique set of challenges and that
in some Industries it's probably even
worse than others but it also brings up
the point what barriers do oh my gosh
now we're gonna talk about Weinstein I
am so tired of these women playing
victim about Weinstein you slept with
dude for a role then you knew what
you're getting yourself into why does
the man go to prison why don't the women
go to prison too if you sleep with a guy
for a role why does only he get in
trouble you partooking it too oh oh
because he's more powerful because he's
got power so you have Beauty that's a
form of power I'm sorry beautiful women
absolutely have a power over men you can
get away with so much more when
you're beautiful oh my gosh the amount
of I've seen men put up with
because a girl is beautiful it's a form
of power and you can agree with it you
can disagree with it but it's true it's
there but only the men are in trouble
from being power
and facing the workplace do you think
there are some Industries where women
are paid more than men I I don't really
know I guess like maybe like one that
comes to mind is like perhaps modeling
modeling it's a tricky industry because
it comes up to the status of the model
Kendall Jenner because of her status she
is going to be getting paid a lot more
modeling you have skinny models and you
have overweight models you really don't
see men overweight models women have way
more opportunities than men and so it's
evident that the gender pay Gap exists
but what's not really discussed is that
it's for both genders
female models on average earn two to
three times more than male models it
becomes even more towards the top do
they call you Carly billionaire I mean
according to Forbes Gisele Bundchen
earned 33 million dollars while the top
male model Sean O'Pry earned 1.5 million
and it's not just the runways too female
only fans create earn 78 more than their
male counterparts on average when we
look at the top 10 earners 85 of them
are women to be honest it all makes
sense I mean who the hell do you think I
would guess content creation is similar
paying for only fans and similarly in
the world of Fashions with more
designers focusing on women's wear
there's more demand for female models
than male ones so although this may say
something about Society women are
dominating occupations that rely on
one's looks but what it shows is that no
matter what gender demand is the
determining factor that directly impacts
one's pay so I wanted to ask the streets
on whether there are similar aspects in
different Industries do you think then
that there are some Industries where
women have an advantage in versus there
are some Industries where men make more
because there's more of a general
interest in it Sports is a big thing for
men male athlete competitions are more
favored by the public look at the NBA
for example like the WNBA doesn't get as
much streamings as the NBA does because
of this whole cycle of sexism as women
sorry women don't dunk not like the men
they're not as aggressive they're not as
interesting to watch
uh and this has come and I played 16 I
don't even know when I started playing
basketball it might have been more than
16 years ago I played roughly 20 years
of baskets coming from me yeah I think I
started in like second grade first grade
like I was young so yeah so I've been
playing basketball forever and I could
tell you I'd rather watch the men than
the women sorry just is what it is it's
also based on demand wouldn't you say we
live in a capitalist society and
therefore we value people's worth on
demand and that's not that's you know
it's just wouldn't take into account be
the most Fair Way in the most
meritocritic way to determine who gets
paid the most or least yeah that is
based on demand and you know more
companies will get paid depending on how
good the product there is and that hence
kind of what products are popular now
modern days you know so not only does
demand dictate pay it also provides the
whole contest
because when the U.S women's national
soccer team received four million
dollars for winning the World Cup
whereas the men's team received 38
million dollars in 2018 even though they
didn't even qualify sure as hell seems
unfair to me it comes down it actually
seems perfectly fair to me
and I am a female athlete guys all I
cared about the first 24 years of my
life was Sports I didn't give care about
anything else that was it
inequity but when you consider that the
men's World Cup generated six billion
dollars in Revenue whereas the Women's
World Cup generated 131 million the
reality is that the women were paid a
higher proportion approximately 20 of
the revenue while the men were paid
seven percent if you want to talk about
pay disparity the Women's World Cup
players they are yeah I knew it was
something like that I knew it was much
more so I would make it fair because
it's worth noting that the women's team
initially received an offer for a
performance-based contract which they
declined in favor of guaranteed payments
oh
my gosh
oh my gosh I would love to talk to one
of these women
it was only after winning the World Cup
the team realized that they would have
earned more if they had accepted the
original offer which led to the lawsuit
you can't sue someone for giving you the
contract you asked for this was no
surprise that the judge threw out the
initial case but in 2022 a final
decision was settled the core eventually
rolled for a 24 million dollar
settlement in favor of the women's team
and it represented an historic victory
for a team that was oh my gosh the
entitlement
you know this is so disgusting I I am I
am repulsed by this I am repulsed
feels success in terms of wins the
players coming up next will have a much
better ability to just play and so
whether it be Sports modeling corporate
or even as a YouTuber ideally the most
Fair pay is based on the income that
someone brings in and not their gender
and it's exactly why I probably
shouldn't be getting paid as much money
as Emma Chamberlain yet but it raises
the question how about jobs where it's a
bit more difficult to measure value why
do you think women are underrepresented
in certain positions that are very
desirable at the moment such as stem
jobs as well as even executive jobs in
general is not that they're not getting
the opportunities they have to apply to
these jobs I'm a network engineer I'm a
plan engineer I work outside women can't
just start from here and go to there but
we are seeing that if women get into
jobs that are men dominated you actually
have an opportunity to move up this is
going to take time this just started
happening people have to get positions
and you have to stay in those positions
but is this truly the case
because even though women have dominated
heel jobs representing 67 percent of
health care workers studies found that
the average pay for women is about 24
lower than men that pay Gap exists now
if you're a woman that seems pretty
unfair one city a 1.5 million
hospitalizations found that female
doctors patients had significantly lower
mortality but despite this female
Physicians still earn 10.9 percent less
in revenue from Office visits compared
to male counterparts in a traditionally
male-dominated fuels like stems studies
reveal that women are earning fifteen
thousand dollars Less on average so
there's evidence that the pay Gap does
indeed exist for women but again is it
in the way that people commonly think or
are we overlooking important context
because that particular study only
examined the median salary of full-time
stem jobs which means it may not
accurately capture the claim of
different pay for equal work the claim
that the wage gap between men and women
is only due to sex is wrong and so there
may be misconceptions regarding the
precise cause and outcomes of this pay
Gap opponents that say that the gender
pay Gap isn't real would say that it's a
myth propagated by feminism what would
you say to that I mean we ask
yeah I think like the common statistics
out there is like 72 cents to a dollar
but I've also heard like limitations to
that study where they say that it didn't
take into account industry by industry
they took all the different pays and
apparently it didn't account for certain
factors yeah I think it's real but at
the same time you also have women making
more than men so it happens it's not a
myth at the same time you see like
success stories where women are more
like you know successful too so there's
hope so when individual decisions make
up societal impact uncovering the truth
depends on considering the complete
picture and when certain industries have
significant disparities in
representation it may suggest that both
genders tend to have distinct interests
it's whether it's fair or not is our
distinct inherent interests what's
contributing to the Pagan do you think
personal choices also have an account
for example for a woman may be giving
birth do you think that impacts the
gender pay Gap in general biologically
yes there are differences I think it's
person and person because I'm a male
that's interested in caretaking now it's
like a change of roles and people
realizing oh I can do more and same
thing with men let's say two people
working at Home Depot the one biological
male one biological female the
biological female can lift way more than
the biological male I will pay the
biological female way more do you think
that's happening in a macro way in the
in certain jobs men are performing
better and vice versa I believe what
happens is you come in and they say Okay
men and female lifting forklift okay the
milk doesn't work here you wouldn't even
get to the point of the interview to get
to find out about this women are
portrayed as weaker so there's way
easier to just push like no you don't
need more money he just may not be able
to work long hours which men do and that
also will contribute doesn't mean that
somebody works less or less harder just
the difference in like how we leave so
it's not just social differences but
biological differences between men and
women that's contributing further to the
pay Gap it's a nuanced not talked about
enough in this ongoing debate yeah
because we can't do the same jobs men
can do it's like all right
if I hired and you know my industry is a
very Fringe industry like what percent
of people are in entertainment like this
is this is a new not the best example
but but but let's take next door
they're they're paid they're you know
laying bricks
there is no way I could lay bricks you
know me and King if we both laid bricks
for an hour
you're gonna beat me is that even gonna
be close
and you know I like to think we're too
in shape individuals it's like you know
we it's how we're made and you know
there's jobs where I would out earn King
you know based on the fact that I'm a
chick like media it's it's just like
why don't his women instead of whining
we just work in the industries that we
have a advantage in thank you
because even though women generally
begin their careers with equal pay with
men the Gap widens especially when they
have a child I think the real reason
that more women aren't
um yeah
as it should
[Music]
children
are taking significantly more time out
of the workforce due to lower Workforce
participation among mothers aged 25 to
44 compared why don't we look at that
you don't understand King why don't we
look at that as a privilege we get to
spend less time at work and we get to be
home men would want to be home too
I mean it's like that's a privilege it's
like what are you jealous of the your
husband who's probably working more
hours now that you're working less it's
just like childish women in the same age
coupled with the absence of mandated
paid maternity leave in countries like
the US mothers are less likely to pursue
promotions and less likely to get them
I'm not able to put in a hundred percent
at work so I don't feel comfortable
asking for this pay raise or promotion
while on the other hand fathers are more
likely to be in the workforce and also
more likely to experience the fatherhood
premium compared to childless men and
command higher pay due to precede higher
competence commitment and stability but
at the same time is as providing the
full picture because women are
increasingly more likely to attain
higher education while men still make up
the majority of inmates victims of
violent crime and individuals working
lower paying menial jobs and so are we
comparing a relatively small proportion
of successful men to the general
population men are definitely
overrepresentative when it comes to
Executive position but wouldn't you say
that men are also like pretty
overrepresented when it comes to menial
jobs bricklayers sewer system workers
that's true I mean it's hard work so
obviously women probably don't want to
do it well that's a pretty big
generation Nation would you say women
are not as hard working as men yes
yes I would I would I would I'm just
saying me having a call today this is me
I'm not trying to go lay no breaks keep
me out of that feminist shut up
shut up we don't want to be forced to
work in those Industries we do not want
really quality none of us want it shh oh
because when discussing equal
representation should the conversation
just focus solely on desirable
Industries like stem or should it also
focus on blue-collar jobs some that pay
pretty damn well those are
representation of men in these certain
industries explain the fact that men
feel greater pressure to prioritize
financial success even with jobs that
are not traditionally seen as the most
desirable what do you date a guy that
makes less than you no
no well I mean yes if I wasn't single
but I'm not single so that's not a valid
question men have more audacity to make
the ask are more likely to push each
other as men to say hey you got to make
more money you got to make more ask for
more women they think about this
differently maybe more of a timing
Factor say they want to become a mother
or they want to have a family despite
the progress in gender equality is this
pressure on men to prioritize financial
success contributing more to the gender
pay Gap than societal barriers that are
hindering women from achieving the same
because if so what can we do about it
when companies move fast it can backfire
stop whining that's what we can do about
stop whining accept the world as it is
stop trying to change the whole system
and get a job you like and stop whining
Am I Wrong Am I Wrong is there are you
whining King because I'm a YouTuber no
no he's not whining but yet the women
will whine because they don't want to
work 80 90 hours a week and be a CEO of
a billion dollar company
but light you have a company that's due
I want to appease a different audience
and now look what's happening stocks
going down they're losing money as they
should woman in a position where she was
not qualified
yes of course there's a chick behind
that decisions that ended up hurting the
company in the end so it's going to
happen but over time you can't force it
I think there's always going to be
inequality but then in the future I
think the Gap will be smaller we are
going away from the traditional roles
since we are trying to equalize
everything we just will find the right
balance of things and everybody would
get what they deserve and as we continue
to advance to the society it's an
important reminder that in an Ideal
World the equality is a given right but
as history shows it's actually more of a
privilege and with privilege comes
responsibilities because it's only when
we start exploring the nuances of issues
when we will realize that what we truly
want is an equality of outcome but
rather equality of opportunity in your
mind do you think there's gender
equality in America I think the answer
is yes but then you have to uh break it
down in Industries most important thing
about the big difference is the fact
that the conversation is happening
before I don't think it would happen you
know and it's no I'd like the
conversation to stop happening I would
like the whining to stop yes I would
like all the women that are whining
about pay to go marry a rich man yes or
just a guy that'll just pay for your
so you can just stop whining or or
go work as a bricklayer yes I just
wanted the whining to stop only when we
engage in conversation with others and
taking into account the broader
perspective that we can finally realize
that we need each other more than ever
and that's the mission to explore the
unfamiliar so my thoughts are that women
should stop
whining yes yes women I'm tired of the
whining all I want to hear from you is
I'm going to apply to be a bricklayer an
electrician or a plumber when you're mad
about the pay Gap and if you're not
willing to do that I don't want to hear
it but let me know in the comments guys
maybe I'm crazy I don't know maybe I
just I got it all wrong and I just you
know don't know what I'm talking about
do no research whatever you know know
but let me know in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and we'll talk to you next time